So then I learned about, you know,
Bob Miller had me talk about the mast cell and the inflammation
and then in walks air spoke to him is all his brilliance
and teaches me another level about, okay,
open this up.
How do you know if your patient's in flame?
How do you know?
Do they come in and they have, you know, like,
what's going on?
So he taught me and I use those labs right there
at the pull them out of my patient
and I'm looking for a pattern.
I'm looking because it's kind of hard
because people kind of throw around the word and flame
and it's like the knees inflamed or am I inflamed?
But I really didn't take, I kind of took it for granted
or I didn't appreciate it.
When someone has, you know, insulin load
that cell danger response, those things,
that is inflammation.
That will shut down your body's ability to get retoxins.
That's not an ideal situation.
I feel like that keeps people sick.
They just cannot get over the hump.
They can't get rid of their toxins.
So that person doesn't mind me to do.
So what do we do as doctors?
What do we do when these people walk in?
Well, first we always, Eric talked about this.
Dr. Eric talked about the foundations.
Nothing will trump nutrition, hydration, rest, and peace.
Nothing.
You don't get those right.
You don't get to move on to the next level.
So at every visit, we're talking about their nutrition.
We're talking and they're like, oh my gosh,
we have to go, yes, we have to go through it.
We have to go through our hydration
because bile is an equally solution.
If you don't have proper amount of water in your cells,
then your body, your bile is not going to flow.
And I'm going to do a big seminar this weekend
where all I talk about for two hours
is the downstream effects of bile.
Because I learned in medical school
not much, like bile, yep, good, fat soluble vitamins,
that's about it.
And then Eric blew my mind at one of the shy cons.
It's just like thyroid metabolism.
Plus trauma tablet, glucose metabolism, gut function,
sea ball, it's just like, you've got to get your bile rate.
You have to get your bile rate.
So then we identify the triggers.
OK, so what made that mass all activated?
It's probably a combination.
And again, Dr. Eric, physical chemical emotional microbial,
taught me that, look for physical things.
So they have scars, blocking meridians,
so they need an adjustment, they need some laser work, chemical.
I mean, what are you washing your hair with?
What do you put on your skin?
Just do the inventory, clean that up for them.
Do they have a chronic exposure to some chemical?
You can use kinesiology to test for that.
There's something that they're just being exposed to
that keeps on triggering the mass all.
And then microbial, find out, is there something going on?
Do they have a latent virus?
So they have something that's activated
that you're just not catching.
Because those are cumulative, we go after all of them.
We're always asking about all of them.
And at once, we're doing lab tested, figure it out.
We can do muscle testing to figure it out.
And then the emotional.
The emotional, I poo-poo that because I'm a medical medicine.
We don't really talk about emotions.
But I mean, you get upset.
You can feel it and you've got, there's that connection.
It's irrefutable.
So doing things like heart math for the patient keeping track
of their HRV is a really important tool
that I've used in the past couple of years
doing anti-hoppers, dynamic neural retreating
for limbic stuff going, seeing carry right,
getting your spirituality, like settled.
So really addressing that with your patients.
I'm not the one who sits down in, I'm not a counselor,
but I do have tools for that.
I do address that because that will keep them stuck.
That will keep their 2.5.
Their phase 2.5, we're not working.
And then it'll piss off your mast cells.
And you're just in the cycle.
So I try to address all that with everybody.
And then why not give them some things
that calm the mast cell?
They're looking at the literature.
They're safe.
They're effective.
We're going to talk about PGA, which blew my mind when
I started to look at these studies about what
it can do in the randomized controlled trials that, again,
take 17 years to get into the doctor's office.
And maybe they never will, because they're not
profitable enough.
So looking at that and then having USNs,
back that and bringing it to you, I think that's awesome.